so senator guido can you tell me why
you're here
yes madam chair senate bill 376. oh okay
good
that's an easy one
yeah okay so
bob dyed a senate district two uh prime
sponsor senate bill 376 bill that i
think is very important to the future
and i know the policy issue has been
decided there are a couple of changes
here the one 1.1 million should be
sufficient
uh and then in the amendment that's
presented by john skipper
i don't know if you have that but i
think you should
was this he's got 1.2 million
wait what amendment was that i'm looking
at uh
29.88
21 april
1.2 would suffice um
mickey d that that wasn't part of our
that wasn't part of what we voted on
yesterday
i think there was a floor amendment
adopted yesterday that increased the
appropriation of 1.2 oh and that's in
the bill now as amended before this
committee okay i didn't see that that
would be sufficient uh one so you want
1.2 would work i think 1.1 would work it
might be tight 1.2 would definitely work
i can give you the computation basis for
that if you'd like
so
that number is derived as derived by
taking the number of towns and cities
which is uh
221 towns and 13 cities so that's 234
municipalities
48 already have one trained cit officer
the state police have 100 or so trained
officers we need 10 sheriff's
departments and two corrections
facilities to have a person each so that
bring the total to
um
to
officers to be trained okay except we
also know that many towns don't have
police departments okay okay i mean
up north we don't have police
departments in every town so
that would be the committee's discretion
yeah i just
patterning this to get the model out
there
so uh at that at forty seven hundred
dollars uh it's forty the high 46 and
change per training
uh for each officer the cost the total
costing
uh not including the cost of the course
itself
all right so there'd be eight courses at
12 500 a piece over over the period of
time that would train all the officers
that we want trained by this program now
that's not including the towns that
don't have
officers in them so that's your
discretion
um come up to about a million
13 000
give or take so 1.1 million would be
fine the thing that's that's not in the
bill that needs to be
is that these funds need to be
non-lapsing
because they're going to go over the end
of the fiscal year
and so the anticipation is that they
would train one class for each of the
next eight months and if you notice i
think the bill as i saw it now i'm not
sure is what you have
uh
made these funds expendable by or
appropriate these funds for the year
ending june of 22
that wouldn't be sufficient
okay uh well it says
fiscal year ending 30 june 23. okay then
that's been repaired okay
um
okay that's about it i would ask the
committee to you know keep its pencil
sharp but this is definitely a program
that's needed
um
i had a call this morning 20 minutes on
the phone from a gal that was arrested
and cuffed she was a rape victim and and
ptsd in the whole nine yards and the
chief had to come tell the young officer
to take the cuffs off mm-hmm you know
she was stopped for
minor infraction
and when she saw the police officer get
all frazzled and those types of things
happen so this training is necessary and
i would appreciate your
uh you know your support for it will i
answer any questions no i don't have any
thank you
oh i'm sorry representative heath has
one um now will that i didn't read all
this i'm sorry um
will the training come out of our police
standards
training
the funding well yeah the training
courses will be approved because
currently police standards and training
does one course but there is another
outside agency it might be nami but
there's another agency that does it
they'd have to be approved by police
standards and training okay the funding
would all be done through the
administration of police standards and
training with this one point one great
okay thank you
okay anybody else
okay
uh mickey i do have a question
on on the language and the appropriation
i'm not real sure that that's correct is
it
in what
in what way the appropriation is
non-lapsing
that was part of the floor amendment
that was adopted yesterday as well so
it's appropriated in fiscal 23
for the purposes stated in section 7 of
the bill
okay so we don't have to have the
governor draw a warrant or anything like
that uh there there is warrant language
standard warrant language uh on the very
tail end of the bill uh starting on line
11 on page three oh you mean i only read
to line ten
[Laughter]
line 11.
okay i don't have line 11.
and and just make sure everyone does
have them the proper version of this
bill uh it was amended yesterday so the
amendment would have been
four h hopefully you see that in the top
left corner of the bill
okay okay so this is old
the one i had it could if it was as
amended by the senate that's a a
previous version
it should say as amended by the house is
the most recent current version of this
bill okay
things are changing quickly
correct that's the current version
correct okay uh the other thing that i
have is
i don't
think it's a good idea
to create another board
since we
already have this new
board
that created out of leak
i don't i just
i think we just need one
one people
one group of people from
you know whatever the this new board is
made up of and it was kind of a cross
section of um
of officers that i i'm just not
real excited about
creating another board and police
standards and training
so if i may madam chair um this board
would not be overseen by police
standards in training this would be an
independent board this is a study
committee to look at establishing a
board
currently as you know the attorney
general investigates every every
shooting
their determination however is
exclusively limited to the to the
criminality or not of the actual
justification
in the in the use of lethal force
there's nothing to address
the issue of
whether there might have been
instances or or circumstances that would
have allowed an intervention prior to
getting to that point ergo the mental
health issue this board would only look
at
mental health
components of any shooting to see if
there's anything we can adjust in our
training
for police officers going forward or how
we might adjust our current policies
uh that's not within the purview of the
board from lee act this one is
specifically
and exclusively for mental health review
of police shooting incidents none of the
information can be disclosed similar to
the hospital situation hospitals have a
review board as well
and that none of that can be used it
cannot be okay so who who is going to
control this board
well that would be determined by the
study committee that's going to
determine whether to establish the board
so this bill doesn't establish a board
it establishes a study committee because
it's very sensitive issue police
officers don't want you know they're
worried about you know how could this be
used or not so rather than establish
that board we're establishing a study
committee to look at establishing the
board i think that's an important
component of this
i'm not a fan of study committees as you
know but in this case i think this needs
to be looked at pretty carefully
oh yes
somebody else asked a question so you
know i mean i'm just wondering though
would
could the study committee
could the study committee be
could this be rewarded that the study
committee would with its jaw its purpose
would be to see
if the current
committee established under laid act
could be expanded not expanded but its
duties
you know increased to encompass what you
want here because it does seem like to i
mean to just have two
you know to to have two separate
committees looking at that
let's say a police use of deadly force
rather than you know each with a sort of
a separate assignment rather than one
committee
to do the whole thing uh
you know that's that kind of worries me
i guess
well it worries me too and that
i don't know how i'm not sure that this
would this language is in conflict with
what you're saying right it would study
establishing a mental health incident
review board it that doesn't preclude it
from looking at
considering the leak established board
as that board
i got that but when you say establishing
a mental health incident review board
without saying
whatever the name of the
the liaic board is and i've forgotten
although i gave them money
that i i just
i just think that
all
police review stuff okay
whether it's for mental health or it's
for other things
needs to be in police standards and
training
because
the goal is that i would i would
disagree pretty strenuously madam sure
and the reason is this this board is not
looking at
the conduct of police officers relative
to
anything other than mental health right
and if the leak commission has mental
health experts on it
all right
psych psychologists and so forth that's
one thing i'm not sure that composition
exists on that committee but it could be
expanded to
not not on um
not on a full-time basis
but if you're you know the the key thing
with police standards and training in my
opinion
is that they need to know what's going
on out there so they can adjust the
training
and so if we've got this
something else
the feedback may not be there and that's
that's the part
that concerns me more than anything
yes go ahead
madam chair i agree with a lot of things
you're saying but i also agree with
senator gaida could it be a subcommittee
so there's an inherent communication
tool built in
so that there's a standing group of
individuals that are part of the leak
um there are standards in training that
that
will respond because the issue is a
serious one
and it's ongoing and it seems to be new
things keep happening i would not be a
verse to language that establishes a
subset of lee act that's dedicated to
a mental health review
uh i review the mental health components
of shooting incidents
that that would be acceptable but i as
long as it's clearly stipulated that it
isn't as part of lee act which i'm not
sure that's in it mental health review
board is not in part of its current
language no it's it's not
it's not
mickey can you fix that
you can fix any
so so just to kind of
summarize th this bill sets up a
legislative study committee that's
correct to to come up with a proposal
for establishing an in perpetuity right
committee based on whoever it determines
is your intention here to change the
charge of a legislative study committee
or to establish a different committee
with appointed members besides
legislators
no this it's to
ensure
that
whatever they decide
becomes part of whatever this other
board is
and how that's worked out in the study
committee
is up to them
so if i'd point the committee to page
two
section four of the bill the committee's
duties you'd want to
clarify in there that
part of its recommendation should be to
consider that
to
not only consider it
that it should be part of their
recommendation right right
okay
and
so for example could it say i mean would
you both be would you be comfortable
with this not saying something like
the committee shall
shall study
um
uh
establishing within the whatever the
whatever the late act committee within
the late act commission
commission
um
uh
a mental uh
mental health review mental health
mental health uh or giving that giving
that commission authority to to
review
menta the mental health aspects i'm i'm
just sort of making it up as i'm going
along but basically the mental health
aspects of
the uh
law enforcement use of deadly force
and such non-deadly non-lethal swot
engagements that you know as the bill
says does that make sense
yeah i don't it
mickey knows
yeah i'll i'll take a look and and see
what makes sense to add here and um
i i don't know if if the plan is to
circle back with an amendment at another
day yeah so don't worry about it for i
mean i know we have many workspaces
scheduled coming up i have all kinds of
time
between now and three o'clock on
wednesday
so
um the other thing is i i think we um
we need to go back to the one point 1.1
million
and i
i just say that we're we're talking
you know
they're just a lot of places that don't
have police departments that are
considered towns
and most of those places are covered by
other police departments
yeah you know i'm fine with that i said
if you don't have a police department
it's pretty hard to train somebody in it
right so right i don't know those
numbers neither neither do i
but i know
in just in my area
you know uh chatham doesn't have a
police department
uh albany doesn't have a police
department
tamworth has one police officer
you know
you know that that's just
right around conway so
yeah would the department be able to
ascertain which towns do have police
officers and which don't
they must
i would assume that
police standards and training would know
that
right
am i getting a head shake
they better know that
so yeah i'm fine with that you know
sharpen the pencil make it work all
right sure
okay so um we'll recess this until uh
monday i've got ed i don't and that's
gonna take all day i'm afraid so
i better recess this till tuesday
at we'll take it up the first thing
tuesday morning
no
tuesday morning is like uh
one o'clock
because we've got a executive session
and then we've got a non-germane
amendment hearing
okay
so
tuesday at one
since
if i'm recessing i have to set up
i have to set a time
okay thank you madam chair anybody else
for any questions please call anybody
else want to say anything about
this
you happy
okay great
so
all right
which bill did you have an amendment for
401 okay
um
i told transportation to
wait until two because i want to
take up this uh 394.
okay unless is transportation are the
people in transportation out there
huh
is kathy out there
oh okay
all right well then
let's go to 394.
is there somebody here that wants to
talk about this
okay and your amendment's on 401 all
right okay
okay fine we'll
we'll hear from the department
hello so for the record i'm chris bond
i'm counsel to the department of
education
i'm also the attorney general office's
client counselor to the department of
education so i'm actually
here in that capacity as well today
testifying on behalf of the attorney
general's office as well who has an
interest in this bill and um
specifically i
my understanding is that the committee
has questions about the financial impact
and my my colleague rebecca fradette
will
will be able to speak to that um
the uh purpose of my testimony was to
reiterate a concern that i had um
testified to in front of the uh house ed
committee about
um and that is
specifically a
first circuit holding from a couple of
years ago
that
creates significant risk that the
current law as structured
violates the requirements of the idea
and so
um
the attorney general's office feels that
there's significant risk that if the age
limitation isn't changed to go through
the age 21 inclusive which means up to
the 22nd birthday that there's a
significant risk that a court would find
that
uh
that violates the requirements of the
idea and i could speak to that in more
detail if you want but we are aware of
at least one advocacy group that is
preparing a lawsuit they're sort of
waiting to see what the resolution of uh
of this uh legislative attempt at a fix
is um we anticipate that they would sue
the state and then we are aware of
multiple due process hearings that have
been brought against individual school
districts
on the basis of this first circuit case
it's called kl versus board of education
um
and uh we know of at least one instance
where the parties settled and it's our
understanding that the district agreed
to provide the services
as uh as the plaintiffs argued the idea
required
we're aware of at least one other due
process hearing that will probably go
forward if and only if the legislature
doesn't act so my understanding is that
what came up when there was a floor
amended offered yesterday was some
concerns about the fiscal impact um
due to the fact that
if the
effective date of the age change was
made to be effective immediately
districts had not had an opportunity to
to budget for that and plan for that i
certainly understand that practical
concern i think from a legal perspective
the significant risk that the state law
is currently in violation of federal law
is un is on sort of unmoved by that uh
practical consideration in other words
um it's uh and i i hesitate to use
language that is too um decisive because
the state might be in a position of
having to defend this law but there's a
significant risk that the law uh
currently structured violates the idea
and i don't think that risk is at all um
mitigated by the fact that districts
haven't had a chance to to to plan for
that i think the argument would be that
the we're currently in violation federal
law so districts and the state already
have this obligation imposed on them by
the idea that's the uh at least that's
the argument so that's what i wanted to
make sure the committee understood um
and i'm happy to take any questions and
again to the extent you will have
specific um financial impact questions
and i'm sure you do i'll have to defer
those to my colleague uh ms verdette
okay
so attorney bond is
the way this bill is right now
does this meet the needs
of
idea
the the aged language
uh as in the in the draft that i'm
familiar with that i understand to be
the current draft um in my view does
meet the
uh
the idea requirement that is the age 21
inclusive language that requires the
special education services to be
provided up to this 22nd birthday i
believe that is adequate as far as the
um
effective date i mean i believe that the
there's a significant risk that our law
is
not
um in keeping with the requirements of
federal law until that effective date
whenever that is so to the extent that
the effective date on the on the version
i'd seen was far in the future i think
maybe june 2023 i think that there's a
significant risk that we would be held
to be in violation of the idea
but as far as the actual language of the
bill um
i i think it's sufficient yes okay i i
just wanted to make sure that we were
okay here sure
okay so you're suggesting
on the um
uh
effective date
is
upon passage
or yeah i mean just to be clear i think
the the argument
is that we are
in violation of federal law until that
age has changed so
the longer we
the longer that effective date is pushed
out the longer we remain
in violation and no longer we're suscept
or arguably in violation i should say um
and the
we will remain uh you know vulnerable to
lawsuits both at the district level
because people have the ability to to uh
to
pursue actions directly against school
districts on the basis of the ida and at
a state level because we do know that
there's a plaintiff that's interested in
pursuing us um and other states that
those kinds of cases have been
successful including in rhode island
so
the
the um
i i always thought that it was
21 but obviously that wasn't what was in
the law
i knew that i knew the schools had to
take care of them through their
you know 21st
birthday or whatever but obviously this
didn't say that
so um
the financial
effect is
however many
children
each school district has
that has
disabilities
and that seek services because there's
no obligation to to stay in and seek
those services so i think we can speak
generally to the population of children
that are
that are hit that age group which is not
a large population but then we don't
know how many of those will choose to
continue um their education because they
they aren't required to
okay
yep no problem
okay okay
that's all i oh go ahead represent
sure
turn this on so this has long been a
problem in school districts um i found
out about it simply by happenstance when
i was an educator in manchester and had
a student that said today's my birthday
and i'm turning 21 and i can't come to
school anymore
and i think there was a shock factor for
me and that goes back to i think 1982
when i found out about this situation i
was so shocked because this young lady
didn't have any place to go she had her
she was a foster child she'd been signed
up for adult services but it took a
while for that to keep him but anyway
the purpose of this amendment that has
just come to me um and i would like to
propose it
it this amends the bill by replacing all
after section 3 with the following
for the fiscal year ending june 30th
2024 the department of education shall
be liable for all school district costs
related to providing services to special
education students over age 21 to age
22.
the department shall identify a means by
distributing reimbursement to school
districts within the same fiscal year in
which services have been provided
provision of such services does not
obviate adult development
disability services for which a student
over 21 years of age may qualify under
rsa 171-a
now in this amendment i see that we have
here it's 24 and then we have the act
takes effect 2023
so my concern is based on what you just
said
that we have a more urgent need to um
initiate this legislation sooner
so would you like to see this amendment
read 22
well
let's let me just let me just make sure
we understand
this is saying that doe will pick up the
cost but one year only
one year only where does it say that
within the same fiscal year in which
services have been provided
yeah
well the intent mickey
the way this is drafted on line five
you'll see it says for the fiscal year
ending june 30 2024 i think the intent
was this would apply to one fiscal year
and not be in perpetuity yes
and this would assist districts
they have they have a lot of money out
there
seriously
that they haven't claimed for anything
which is another issue
but
i hate you you know um
okay so
the other thing is that i like this
inclusive
over age 21 whatever that language is
and 21 inclusive
you know i i don't want to say the age
22 because then
that's
if we're using 21 inclusive then that's
the term we should use i think
across the board
okay
yes please
it appears to me that the
um
the bill itself as amended 1538 h
with a simple change the effective date
upon passage accomplishes what we're
trying to
accomplish
without adding
an additional amendment to me this
amendment for to me is very confusing it
kind of throws in a bunch of other
things that don't need to be there if we
simply
make the effective date sure so yeah if
i can respond to that and also to
representative heath's question so i
think i really
want to make clear to kind of bifurcate
the question of who would pay for the
services is a policy decision that the
attorney general's office wouldn't weigh
in on
the question of the effective date of
the change to have the age 21 inclusive
language that's the issue that we have
and i agree that to change it to
effective on passage
allays that concern the attorney
general's office has to the extent
there's a significant risk that we're
out of step with the federal requirement
um
as for the
whether at this amendment i think the
ag's office would just be agnostic
because it's a policy decision but to
the extent that the act's effective date
would be july 1 2023 or and uh that
would be
continue to be problematic and still
subject us to significant risk of
lawsuits based on the federal statute so
i hope that answers both of you
well i don't like these kind of
surprises
can i just mention one more thing
with regard to the payment by the
department for those students
schools have set their budgets at this
point in time
and if in fact there becomes a
requirement for
the students
for whom were were
creating this situation or trying to
remediate the situation for it's a very
very small population of children and i
think the department can agree with me
and the children with the absolutely
most severe of disabilities some are
often in
residential placements
some
require a great deal of support even to
remain in a a regular education
environment
so there's considerable cost so for
those school districts that had believed
that in fact
a number of students would not be part
of their school district
this would relieve the impact of a
change in legislation
and the requirement these children
continue to the age of 21 um or
however we're going to put it um
so it would be a relief to school
districts to help them out with their
special ed budget mary i need to i need
to know what the department is
projecting before we argue whether or
not we want the department to pay it
okay okay that's
so are there any other questions for uh
attorney bond
no
with the date though that we have to put
yes
upon passage okay
thank you
and thank you
we've not met before it's a pleasure oh
pleasure mine thank you okay
all right so who's going to talk about
money
well
good afternoon my name is rebecca ferdet
i'm the state director of special
education
um i we had completed the fiscal note
for this bill in its original form um
and we had been asked
about students who were in separate
schools and so there are six currently
in the 21 22 school year there were six
students who were in a residential
placement i mean you can see all of this
we were then asked and it's not part of
the fiscal note some different questions
by representative vlad at the last
hearing he had asked how many students
were currently 21 within the state and
there are currently four students who
are 21 within the state um and they are
set to graduate at the end of this year
there are currently um 186 students who
are 20 years old
so that's the population i think that um
was was in question
okay so you said
six in residential placements
but that was at the beginning of the
year so
numbers have changed slightly no i mean
yep
let's just assume that that's the right
number okay i mean when you're when
we're talking whatever we're talking
ten dollars doesn't make up pillow beans
okay so we have six residential
and how many or 20
so there's 186 that are age 20
okay and there are four that are age 21
okay
and how many are between 18 and 20.
i do not have that number
i apologize
i i would say that it's pretty close to
the same for each each age level right
around the 186 190 um most most of our
population graduates when they're 18 and
then it's the population gets smaller
and smaller with each year up to 21. so
um i would just
just knowing those numbers i would say
it's probably right around 200 that are
19 and then a much larger number in uh
age 18 excuse me
but the 18 year olds the school is
already taking care of them
yep most of most of them have gone
through when they graduate at 18 um and
this is just the population of 19 to 21
now and with this bill would be up to
22.
okay
all right
and then um you would ask about cost if
we so we have a cost per pupil and
currently it's right around just under
18 000 per child and we pay this out for
special education aid with the passage
of this
um bill we would be allowed to provide
special education aid to students up to
age 22 which we have not been able to do
um so if a school district had chosen to
keep a child after 21 they would pay
that out of their own local funds rather
than through special education aid or
through their idea funds
so how did you get to the eighteen
thousand per student
that comes from caitlyn's office okay
well come on up caitlin don't don't be
sitting back there in the corner
thinking
thinking i could i don't see you
here i'll bring my own chair
um yes
right so um we calculate the average
cost per pupil so we do our regular
average cost per people then we do an
estimated average cost per pupil oh so
this is not
the
this is not just for special ed correct
um this is
this is for
the 18 000 is the average cost per
student in school exactly not anything
to do with
aid yes and that's the number that's
then used to generate the three and a
half times that is in catastrophic state
special education aid
okay
so
um
do we have to is there
is there anything in here
that
says
uh children with disability
can
continue to
go to school
yeah
that's probably the wrong term but you
know that we would pay
the um
the regular adequacy grant for
so if um
if those kids are to stay in school
through 22 we would pay the adequacy
grant for those kids during that time
period okay no matter what the age
as long as they are enrolled
yes up to 22. yeah
remember
they don't call it candidate but of
course
they'd be still eligible for that date
so um
sure i believe the difference
be terribly significant
based on depending upon the percentage
at which special ed eight is paid out
or that small number of students who
might be eligible
um there probably wouldn't be a large
number of but it would um if
the districts would have to pay up to
the three and a half times right so
that's right around um sixty two
thousand 000 so that would be a cost
that they had not planned on from 21 to
22. and that's what this amendment if we
were to accept it would cover
so we would want that 62 000
um and i'd want to point out if you if
the committee does actually want to do
it this way you have about one and a
half million dollars of excess
appropriation from state special
education aid in the fiscal year 22
budget
um i think the amendment would need to
clarify that that money would be
specifically used for this and kind of a
whole different section written for that
but that money would already be existing
in the state budget for that for one
time only
you said that was 1.1 i think it's 1.4
1.5 million
1.4 something
that's that's due to um there was
appropriated about 33 million dollars
this past year and our total bill which
we pay on january first of every year um
was only 31 million dollars so there's
some excess appropriation okay
so
what i'm hearing is that you think you
have the dollars to cover
this
uh so unless every unless all
186 students stay until they're 22 if
all 186 stay until they're 22 it would
be about 3.3 million just for the cost
per people
but we know that's not going to happen
but every team makes a determination
they may say the student isn't going to
stay they may say the student is
i mean that's
to those 186 teams to make that
determination realistically we don't
have the individual expenditure
information on these children right now
so
maybe
they're not children anymore is the
problem and that's that's another issue
you know when you're 18 you're supposed
to be able to make decisions for
yourself well but for the individu if i
may
sure for the children
young adults for whom we're discussing
they really are in need of extensive
care oh i don't argue that really are
not
for many of them
moving into adult services
is the probably the best option a very
this is a very one percent one and a
half percent maybe we're talking about
of of children with disabilities
so for that population they should be
going into some kind of adult care or
the most extreme cases those children
will be staying in a facility some kind
of either a nursing home or some kind of
a facility um so
i just think that this is a move that
i had hoped to see many many years ago
as a special ed teacher
working with children with disabilities
my
caseloads would be big at a high school
level
most of my students would always
graduate
a very very small small population of
children would have to go stay till
they're 21
and
moving on to 22 it's mostly those most
severe cases i believe that we are
talking about
within this bill
i mean that's my experience and then my
experience as as assistant
superintendent dealing with children
with disabilities the same thing
especially in residential placements so
so tell me why we need this study
committee
that was an amendment that happened
after the hearing so i didn't hear the
discussion around the study committee
represented do you think we need a study
committee
personally i don't but i there must have
been a reason no
they're they're
not necessarily the fact is we need yeah
for the sake of a commission i think the
ag's office answered what the study
committee would have said yeah um and i
think
as former deputy commissioner the agg's
decisions were very valuable to me and i
didn't go through my life at all without
talking to their office every single day
so i would feel comfortable if we could
move
toward
doing what the ag's office has guided us
to and by providing relief to those
school districts
for those students by taking this
amendment as maybe we need to make some
changes in it yeah um i think we cover
the basis of keeping the school
districts
whole
and also addressing the needs of our
children with disabilities that whatever
reason have really it would be in their
best interest to remain until they're
22.
and it would be a very very small number
okay so
i'm in favor of getting rid of this
stupid competition
yeah
okay
yeah and the legislative members oh yeah
four
three four
five six
the speaker will love it
that we have eliminated a commission
yeah
i mean
i mean obviously you would be the person
from doe that would be on this
commission do you think it's worthwhile
as i said i did not hear the discussion
around the um for the purpose of the
commission oh don't i would feel
uncomfortable don't evade me no i don't
i really don't i like i had a brief like
view of it i don't even really know
everything that it says so i i would
hate to say something okay i think that
the intention was to find out more
information about the older children
that are staying longer um but i i i'm
not i mean
you will know that when we get the um
um
whatever they call that
request for funding no when we get the
uh
yeah the counts the student counts well
we'll know that
okay anyhow
so mickey get rid of that
whatever it is
all of it
and
and um
d.o.e
seems to think they would have
sufficient dollars and whatever they
call that
for
not only that's entirely sufficient um i
think if you were interested in using
that money you would need to one talk
about
that it would need to be an allowable
use of this money and that we would
fully fund it not just use the state
special education aid formula to make
the money non-lapsing at the end of
fiscal 22 because right now i believe it
lapses
and then three potentially make it
prorated if there's not enough money for
all of the kids
that'll work
got all that mickey
i know caitlyn's just at the other end
of the phone line
well
go ahead
i think i think there's a question
of what period you would want this to
apply to
so the amendment came before you
applying to a future fiscal year and
there's been discussions of making this
upon passage
making this upon passage
are you trying to make this apply to the
21-22 school year only or 22-23 or all
so we would need some clarity on what
period you would want these
reimbursements to apply to 22-23
i mean we can't
you know and i
i know you said that you'd like it
effective upon passage so we'll let the
school districts pick up six months of
uh the cost and then
the um
the state will pick up the costs for 23
and then we'll budget something for 24.
that would take care of the remainder of
this budget then that's true this could
be part of a budget deliberation right i
mean you know school is only
what a month and a half
yeah may and june two months
and everybody gets out on the 15th of
june so
most most everybody so
they'll have to pick up the cost for
this year
we'll put the state will pick up the
costs for
next year
and then it'll go into the budget for
24 25.
does that does that all work
many of them do yes so could we include
that in this
that's typically part of their um that's
typically part of their special
education aid and their entire
not to mention that uh
there's probably
i'd hate to say how much is out there
for summer programs
esra yeah as for money
so the schools can certainly
figure out
i am just so angry
about how much esra money is out on the
table
that i can't stand it
and so every time i think about it it
just
i try not to can i say one thing about
that you can say anything because i also
we just heard our school district budget
the other night and i too was like irate
because they've only spent 10 million
dollars
and the problem is there
there's not a way to show in esser that
you were encumbering money
for the upcoming school year
you have to
first obligate it and spend the money
before you can draw it down from the doe
right
so that is correct but you can show it
as obligated in the grants management
system so we have a column called
allocation and then we have obligation
and then that can go through the end of
the allowable period of grant which
is through 24 i believe so if they were
planning on spending money next year
they could show that as obligated and
then
the drawdown means it has actually been
expended so we do have a large amount of
money that has been has not been drawn
down i'm not sure the amount of money
that has been unobligated at this so can
do school districts understand that they
should be doing that
i believe so
i would say the answer to that is yes i
hope so but
i might be calling you up from
manchester again yeah come meet with us
again yeah but it's uh we do one of
those annually i know it just it just
drives me crazy i
and it's not you know what cares
whatever the first one was there's still
money in there
madam chair i agree with you i can't
tell you when i worked at the department
i used to beg folks at points to spend
their federal money in a timely fashion
so they wouldn't lose it i agree
okay
caitlin is not your fault all right
yeah
i know i mean if you want to give it to
me i can spend it you know i need a new
ferrari
don't you
oh you want a maserati
[Laughter]
okay so we have some amendments on
on 374
and i guess
we'll get all that
straightened around
in 20 yeah in 23.
yep
sure um i don't want to miss something
i'm sorry i ne um i received an email
from representative cordelli this
morning and he asked me to pass along to
the committee that he heard from a
parent yesterday who is planning a due
process challenge if the law is not
changed with an effective i just wanted
to make sure i told him i'd convey that
and i had not so thank you
i love threads
yeah it's fixed
you could okay
yeah and
um
i will i will let representative vlad
know that i cancelled his commission
that's okay
i'm canceling something else he put in
too so
he'll be happy with me for the rest of
the
year
yeah okay so um
all right
look at us flying through this stuff
i thought i thought this was going to
take us forever to get through but
anyhow
yeah
right something oh hi come on in
come on in
we're we're just knocking this stuff out
like crazy
we've got an amen we got an amendment
first
not you
well come on up
no you can sit down
oh okay
go ahead so uh marty jack hillsborough
36 which is nashua uh i happen to be in
can you hang on to a secretary
we'll make up something about it
no
oh here it is
sorry
okay all right so 401 went through the
criminal justice committee because of
the body worn camera
uh provisions uh i happened to be
subbing in the committee that day
and there's 66 million dollars of
highway funds for state aid bridge and
formula a that are included in the bill
also
the municipal association brought
suggested language the purpose of the
language is to allow towns to accept and
expend these funds without having to
have a town meeting first so that they
could use them in 22 and typically the
town will not be having another town
meeting until next year
the way this is drafted it is not
obvious what they changed it starts on
line seven no funds appropriated through
the end of that section
and then on line 16 no funds
appropriated through the end of that
section
and on line 24 the funds appropriated
that's the change
this is exactly what the municipals it
basically carves out an exception uh so
that
uh towns
can't don't ca will will fall under 31
colon 95
and can expend the funds as
unanticipated revenue
and i would i would encourage the
committee to adopt this yes so that they
can expend the funds this year right
transportation has another idea
on the
so we basically need to change how we're
planning to uh send this money out
because
kathy will tell us
we don't want to mess up safety and
transportation but this is the um
this is the 60
yeah the 66 in um
uh
going out
for bridges road repair and you had
mentioned in your email to me that you
thought this was a bad idea
because of how it's constructed um no
not not a bad idea
kathy mulcahy hampson on behalf of the
department of transportation marie
mullins with
me we're with the department's
absolutely thrilled
with 36 million dollars going to
transportation infrastructure
the the um
we haven't spoken to the senate that
brought the um amendment forward in
terms of um their intent
but it it appears obvious that they want
um
funds to go to
the municipalities for transportation
infrastructure
and that's wonderful again the
department's thrilled
the money going into the state aid
bridge
program
is
a little more involved
and the department had received federal
funds through the iija
and
those funds had a certain formula so
there's currently 6.7 or 6.8 million a
year that goes to state aid bridge with
the iija funds
that program doubled
coincidentally with the formulas the
feds had put out it's another 6.7 or 6.8
million
so state aid bridge program has doubled
the 36 million additional under this
amendment going into state aid bridge we
just want
the the committee to understand the
process that's involved with state aid
bridge
and it's um
it's a lot of work it's it's time
consuming and the program's just doubled
so we're doing that work so can i can i
just
can we just
distribute the money
based on whatever form don't shake your
head back there
just
just based on
the formula
without going through
the bridge thing and tell the
communities that it's for bridgework
yes that would be more expeditious but
this is not a formula so much for the
state aid bridge like there is for block
grant aid state aid bridge is a first
come first served they apply for it um
so but they're um if you took the block
grant aid formula or based on the number
of bridges in that community and did a
different type of formula um we just
wanted to come in and apprise the the
committee of the process that's involved
with state aid bridge and
um
it's a year or more from the time we
solicit projects until they're selected
and then there's an agreement with the
municipality
if you want to get the funds out more
expeditiously to the towns
then that would be directing the funds
right to the towns and not through the
state aid bridge we love funds going to
the municipalities for transportation
infrastructure bridge bridges roads um
it's wonderful we just wanted the
committee to to realize that it's not
going out as quickly as the legislature
might want it to if it's in the state
aid bridge program
okay senator senator what
representative graham
you were back there shaking your head
the the um
said i wouldn't see
wherever yeah
just so that because we're on
whatever work session um and we'll also
be it
the options that i see based on what
your questions were is you take the
whole 66 million and turn it into
um an apportionment out to the towns or
you leave
leave it in state bridge aid which then
specifies it's got to be
used for bridges and it is a process and
it is a
cost sharing process with the towns as
as i think everybody here knows
so but if you just do it a straight
apportionment they can use it on any
kind of maintenance and work and
everything else on their their roads and
i'm not sure how many of them can turn
out
that much more money in
as long as we can make it non-lapsing to
the towns
in their town or city budget
that would have to be worked out i i
just
would think that it might be better to
leave it as state bridge aid so that
towns can
look at
okay we have to have our match
and then there is this additional money
of 36 million that we can come forward
and then the
the
department can prioritize who's come in
which which bridges are actually
eligible because some of them aren't and
the federal money
really complicated the whole issue
because not every
municipal bridge it meets the criteria
to use the federal money because of the
length of the bridges
we got a tutorial on that
public works but it it
that's why there was a long list of
different bridges and funding and and
what we passed in in the 10-year
transportation i think i think the goal
of this
was to get the money out quickly
okay and not to spend
a year
in trying to um
fiddle with the bureaucracy
of um
[Music]
transportation i mean
and i understand why why we we all
understand why i i just think that
um
how do you make
if we give say bedford another one point
whatever million which would would be if
we we got uh the full apportionment
we may not be able to do all that work
this year with that money
i mean we would make it
the town can do it themselves okay um
then that might be a way
um to do it rather than bridges um
although there is a long list and i
didn't bring it with me about this stick
of municipal red listed bridges right
but she's got it
but but we i mean
i guess my point is i don't care where
they spend the money
but
yeah no i mean i mean as long as it's
for infrastructure yeah but but the
problem is with bridges
um
if the state's gonna pick up
uh 80 percent uh
of the bridge then
coming up with a 20 match is better than
spending 2 million
on a bridge in town okay i mean and
that's kind of where
i'm looking at from i know what's going
on in bedford and i know
um what goes on across
the others
so what we would have to say
to the towns is that this money can only
be used for
road
repair construction
whatever i don't know what the right
words are
yeah no because infrastructure there's
words in the apportionment uh
statute right now on what it can be used
for you you can use that but it doesn't
get
as she just held up this 200 and some
red listed municipal bridges that
doesn't get taken care of if we don't
keep putting money towards them well
we've got
i mean if i may we could put you know we
could come up with some ideas not on
tuesday at the public hearing like some
other alternatives there's no public
hearing oh there's no public hearing no
okay we're not having a public hearing
okay we'll have another work session
just like this okay well at the next
work session um we could come up with
some other ideas but there's there's
always you know you could direct it as
you say towards bridges to the
communities and then they could provide
a letter of intent to the department of
what bridge or what projects they intend
to use it on so that we can assure that
it's going towards bridges
there might be some different options
and we could bring some different ideas
if you want to get it you know
spent expeditiously
and give that freedom to the towns to be
able to determine what bridge they would
like to prioritize and that type of
thing
go ahead john just um i'm sorry but
represent if you're going it's john
but if you're going to do that
how do you portion it out to all 200
towns and cities
um to make sure that that everybody gets
the because there's only we're only
talking 36 million which doesn't do a
lot of bridges um so would it be still
first come first served or if i got it
would be on an allocation basis so if i
got square footage of bridges in each
town or you know something like
that but we could just use it specific
to bridge the allocation of bridges in
the towns
and then each town would get their fair
share related to the number or size of
bridges that they have
and then that would guarantee all the
towns get money directed to them
that have bridges
towns have yes so go ahead
and fourteen already say that it's not
lasting yeah
yeah
well it's yeah right that's that's at
the state level that's not we have to
direct the towns that they can't just
put it into their rainy day fund and
spend it for toilets
what'd you say
uh the question still would have to be
answered if we do an apportionment on
bridges do the towns and cities still
have to come up with their
match under the under the rsa for state
bridge
um
aid are we just going to say here's this
go out and
first come first ser well whatever you
can spend 100 on this one bridge um to
get it done
and that language would have to be in
there if you're not going to have them
do a match to it
yeah yeah if it's and you could make it
so it's not part of the state bridge aid
program rsa it could be a separate
allocation law you know that gets passed
specifically for this instance not
related to the state bridge aid program
and the rules and that type of thing
but that i mean like but like kathy said
you know that's up to the legislature
and the policy what you want to set
whatever you want to do the department
will follow through if you want to go
through the state of bridge program
we'll do that um
but we you know we wanted to just let
you know that process how long it takes
and let's let's come up with a
new policy for this money for bridges
okay so it doesn't have to flow through
the state aid bridge thing
it just says that we're going to
allocate it equitably or whatever
and you have to tell us what bridges
you're going to fix
is that right and
but anyhow you'll come back
on yeah we can come back tuesday tuesday
but again we haven't spoken i i'm sorry
we haven't spoken with the senate yet so
we weren't sure what their intent was
don't worry about the senate i'll take
care of them
don't tell them we said it was a bad
idea
[Laughter]
oh my i've already forwarded that email
i think following up on uh the chairs
comments i i i would like to
specifically make sure it goes to
bridges i don't want block grants to
towns when somebody decides hey hey
let's put in a new road over here you
know let's take care of the red listed
bridges how you allocate that you know
but
you guys can best decide that but i
think it needs to be the burgess
well madam chair we you're still just
looking at that 36 million that says for
bridges and because there's still
another 30 million which would go out
for
all road
repair maintenance and and the rest
under under the current rsa yes that's
yeah that's correct okay but we just
want to make sure that even in there
that we say
it has to be used for roads
and
you can
keep it for
however long you need until you spend
the last penny
so you don't have any problem with that
no that's that's how the law the block
grant law reads now so okay yep just
those block those requirements are in
the law right now so
okay is there anything else that you
hated about this bill
we love money going to transportation
and historically
we're very supportive of going we really
now we have structured the legislature
recognizing the need
it's tremendous
one thing i would caution on is we talk
about the redless bridges and we
wouldn't want to punish towns that have
been diligent in right
preserving their bridges and doing that
work so that's why we you know think an
allocation a fair allocation to all
communities based on the number of
bridges or square footage would be the
most equitable rather than targeting it
specifically a red list so
i agree
and madam chair i would still suggest
that under the apportionment a
distributions that we include the
language that says they can go ahead and
start spending it
this year
when the when it becomes effective
rather than waiting for our next town
meeting to say oh yeah okay
absolutely you can the day you get it
the selectmen accept it and
or the council association asks for that
yeah
that's didn't get
that's in here
yeah okay
okay
all right
so
my clerk wants your names
kathleen mulcahy hampson for the
department of transportation
yeah m u l c a h e y hyphen
h a m
p
[Laughter]
s o n
and she's she's in charge of
transportation they just
they have they have i have somebody else
with the name of uh
my name's marie mullen
hopefully
a director of finance at d.o.t
and i'd just like to apologize to the
committee that the commissioners could
not be present today it was quick notice
and they all had long-standing um
meeting that they could not change so
no problem i mean you don't have to
apologize we're just
we're just a friendly group of people
that
love to
take care of our friends we appreciate
and we do have some enemies but
yeah
okay thanks
unless you're unless you're interested
in uh dashboard cameras
we're not on um we're not for the um
dash cameras for the inventory fund
that's for the million dollars that's
for local law enforcement but we do have
section four in the
that was added to the bill for
authorizing the department of
transportation to operate dash cameras
in their fleet
oh these are your fleet vehicles yes
oh that's paragraph four yes
okay
sure
um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on that i do have um a couple of
handouts with with pictures
um
the department's seeking the
authorization to operate the cameras
because under this law is prohibiting
surveillance on on the highways so
we were specifically asking for
authorization for this
the reason is one for safety so that
the traveling public and our employees
are
more protected by these cameras
and secondly
as as marie can testify to we do have
some issues collecting for damages
caused to our vehicles
drivers strike the vehicles and take off
we don't have any informational plate
information we can't identify them
it would help one to know what happened
and two to be able to identify the
vehicle in the plate so we can actually
collect damages when the vehicles are
totaled the ones i gave you um are two
of the 25 that have been struck since
january of this year um they're safety
patrol vehicles so we have a d.o.t
employee out on the road in these safety
patrol vehicles and they pull over to
help motorists in need and they're out
of the vehicle and um
one that was struck is going to be
totaled that was the level of damage to
the vehicle
so it's a big safety issue for the
department
did you want to add to that marie with
the claims
yeah i mean it it helps us get the claim
some people drive off but i mean
primarily the the safety
many of you may have seen last month i
think that probably that first picture
on mur they had the video
luckily our employee was in he was in
the vehicle but was not injured um and
so but having that dash cam we were able
to identify the vehicle that struck um
the the employee and thankfully no one
was hurt but
i know the state police have the same
issue but the
um it's a very bad you know safety issue
we want to make sure our employees are
are protected and that we can collect
for any damages i think in that video he
had his own camera on it yeah he had his
own camera in the truck oh the employee
other
questions
sure go ahead how does that uh balance
out with uh you know say
uh videos that you can't use on the
highway supposedly
you know this is a
your freedom to
in other words what are they what are
you going to use the information for is
it going to be deleted after a certain
amount of time i mean we we don't want
this used for
i think it provides that there's no
incident um
that's been recorded it would be deleted
after i think it's three days it's
provided um and otherwise it's over if
there's um
if there's an incident and someone
requests it or the department needs it
we would keep it at the transportation
management center which is secured
it's not put out on a public site or
anything like that
yeah it says
acceptance otherwise provided no video
recording shall be stored longer than
three business days
so you're in age
and a request would be required within
that three days by state police or
somebody else that needs it for
an incident otherwise it gets deleted
and
there would be no nothing kept at the
tmc after that point
oh something
you can't understand that you know this
can be used for nefarious purposes as
far as the you know who whoever i mean
it's
you know we don't want to be under 1984.
circumstance
you know and it's uh that that would
bother me but i i can understand your
point where
a matter of fact i'm thinking of putting
one in i had a couple incidents myself
where you know i didn't uh
i matter of fact you have to eat those
costs sometimes because you don't have
any proof and that and course cameras
are obviously improved so
it's follow-up and representative
petrie's issue this was the
subject to debate on the house floor
yesterday this particular
issue
and you mentioned
incidences and i guess we could go into
a long line of questioning on what
defines an incident you know we talk in
incidents that apply to a d.o.t truck
does it imply to a
d.o.t individual who's outside his truck
um does it uh
going down representative petrie's road
i mean does it uh if the
the truck happens to capture
a
uh citizen doing something can the state
police then say hey we want to
requisition that video and you you see
where some people correct let's go with
this i i understand um from our director
of operations that the um quality of the
video isn't the best um so it would be
something in close close proximity to
the truck that would be captured a
vehicle striking it or a situation with
a person on the side of the road or our
employee it's not a whole
big wide area that's being captured it's
more would essentially what the driver
seen from behind the wheel but i'm not
the best quality
just so you where there are there are
concerns out there about this yes
thank you
again that the
the film would be kept for no more than
three days unless there's a request um
for a legal purpose such as a need for
it in court um
that the department needs to make a
claim against someone for damage to the
vehicle otherwise the video is gone
we're too busy a department to keep tabs
on everybody else in the future
okay
i uh i would hope so
so uh steve did you want to come and
talk about this other
one
the million dollars is that yours
um steve lavoy i'm the director of
administration uh from the department of
safety
the million dollar appropriation is
to fund the existing body and dashboard
camera grant program
for for locals
municipalities to implement dashboard
cameras in their communities and so this
was
established through
through the last budget process in house
bill 2 a million dollars was
appropriated
the program was released we had 29
applicants come through the first
the first program um over 700 and i want
to say 750 760 000
was awarded
um
and we have about a hundred and fifteen
thousand or so left in in that fund so
this would allow us to go through and
offer a second pass for those
communities that weren't able to apply
uh due to timing due to timing within
their
their process and i do see that there's
some language added here to address the
the local process acceptance of the
funds too
but i'm happy to answer any questions
that you might have about the grant
program itself
or anything else related to it but it is
a program that we at the department
administer these funds we don't receive
them this is just passing those funds on
to the locals based on their
applications
you probably said it and i probably
missed it is the current fund already
totally wiped out
we have about
120 000 dollars
uh left okay thank you
how many
how many went out do you know how many
dash cams
i don't know the total number of cameras
there were 29 there were 29 communities
who received funding okay and it varies
i mean some were very small where
there's only a handful and there's some
that were that were larger
okay and what's nice about the program
is it's it allows the community to
choose whichever model
will fit for them
there's a couple different approaches
with body cameras you can
go with a hosted solution and lease the
equipment you can buy the equipment and
keep your servers on site
you know the the grant program itself is
silent whichever options work for the
community will be considered
yeah we did it in two mm-hmm
yeah
and we were hoping that
it would be taken up
and i would like to say in those
discussions we had requested a position
to help us administer it um that
position is filled that's the only
reason we were able to really get this
out timely and um based on our
assessment we we don't need any
additional um staff support for the
second tranche of funding good
for this for this million dollar amount
if the amount changed we might have a
different discussion
well
that was a temporary position right
correct yeah
okay
are there any other questions on 401 any
other comments
i see some people that had nothing to do
on a friday afternoon
that
that joined us of which i'm very happy
so um
kathy
and marie will get something back if you
could get something to mickey like on
monday
then
what
or sooner oh okay
like saturday oh
okay
so um
is there anything else
oh just just so everybody knows we're
gonna start at nine o'clock
on monday
and we have
i think it's four education bills that
we're gonna take up
a boy
i i just
i just hate to schedule you for monday
afternoon
not knowing how long those bills are
going to
take for 401 yeah we have a work session
already scheduled for uh tuesday for
senate bill 401 because it's after the
public hearing on the non-jermaine
amendment yeah but we just did that
today right
i did what today the
uh or was that already on the schedule
we well 401 was today but it was
scheduled twice so it was our schedule
for a work session so you don't have to
recess this to tuesday if you're okay
with waiting until tuesday to revisit
this
yeah but maybe i'd like to do it well if
we wanted if yeah if we want to do
monday along with the education bills we
could recess this till then yeah well
i think we'll just wait
because
i was surprised at how quickly the um
uh
special ed thing went
so
yeah it did
okay so nine o'clock monday morning
education
you're gonna be in athens
um
you know
so have fun
enjoy the weather
don't get sick
okay thanks all
thank you for
spending your friday afternoon with me
well it's you know you know the concern
yeah i mean
and we he got those concerns yesterday
you know
that's unfortunate